this section comes late in the video but
I have to use it as this is a clip
because it's just that remarkable this
entire thing is what gabs converted our
lounge into an engineered great blanket
fort that's ever been made welcome to
the middle of winter in Cape Town
it may look warm but it's cold trust me
gaps just keeps on finding us these
Autobots in the middle of no way that
just keep us toasty
Joey Joseph Daniel jr. is today's
inmates you catch yourself here right
now
so therefore Dan Joey gabs what are you
guys doing in the middle of the hills of
eyes in that creepy we had cottage over
there
great question so you've seen before
what an important role Joey plays in the
life of gaps and I he brought the ring
when I asked gabs to marry me we've
disguised them as a sheep to make him
new friends taking him surfing and then
he was also the ring bearer at arguably
the most eccentric garden wedding during
the lockdown period he is literally the
centerpiece in our lounge and now he's
just turned 14 years old so he wanted to
do something super special for him gabs
and I then sat down and put on our
thinking caps
to be taken to the snow it's so cool
because this is the only time I'll ever
be able to see the snow because he's too
old to fly this is super super rare for
Cape Town we never get snow here only
sometimes up north so if we're going to
be exciting for Joey but for gaps and I
- this video is brought to you by story
blocks and as I've said before that
doesn't alter my content there's no red
tape I still get to do what I want to do
and get supported for it so rad big apps
story blocks story blocks is an
incredible stock site for motion
graphics footage and audio are you story
blogs all the time for my motion
scrapbooking but I'll tell you more
about that later
we drove north through the Hyuga know
tunnel and up through an epic mountain
pass on to higher ground otherwise known
as cirrus it's honestly such an epic
Drive and if you're ever fortunate
enough to come to Cape Town I highly
recommend it this is completely
ridiculous but on the way up we watched
a painting pink and cabs found really
amusing which made it worth it for me
Joey not so much for him his chicks like
catching his tail take way more skill
and I'm inclined to agree
we then stopped over at this cabin in
the woods which might have been kind of
a horror movie where chainsaws and sheds
involved but that's just my anxiety I'm
sure it was really safe however it was
freezing cold but that's where we found
bass the bar that I showed you in the
intro and the next morning we woke up at
the crack of dawn and headed up the
mountain with a very very excited Joe
gang to the snow
hey I've been given this road map and we
hit it on this 4x4 track the whole way
up there oh yeah yeah check yeah I'm
pretty proud of this one pretty smooth
[Music]
this radio is called oopsy because if
you fall off that cliff over there well
then after two hours of bouncing around
on the gravel roads we finally reached
the snow in New York the dogs walk
around with balloons on their toes in
winter to keep them warm so that's what
we're gonna do for you boy it's got
beautiful mittens what's he gonna think
about this weird cold white powder
beneath his balloon covered toes
[Music]
Joey has such a contagious smile it just
brings me so much joy when I see how
happy he is since Joey was having such a
good time we decided to build him a snow
sausage dog Joey was so excited for me
to show you the snow sausage dug that
mom and dad made for him it's a complete
replica of him splitting image we had a
hit home so that I could edit as well as
fold this now I don't have a name for it
yet you can definitely help me with the
name for this senate's by far the most
complicated eccentric idea that I've
ever had and I decided to execute on it
which is what if you had to connect all
these different power tools along here
and bear in mind this is only half of
them to come around the back here and
put them into one console NICTA to a new
pillow and a synthesizer as well as its
high pressure sprayer would it be
possible to make a really gnarly bass
heavy track sample with all of this
shift behind me
I say of course it would bear in mind
it's really far from completion but I'll
show you around yeah this metal piece
that goes into the chainsaw to give it
like a deep flow will have these leaves
into it that we saw operated nicely the
angle grinder needs to throw sparks
haven't really figured out what to do
with the drill the end both of these
don't think really around the electronic
samples this bungee cords are gonna be
set up separately add a bit of like a 6
string bass
[Music]
obviously sounds like [ __ ] right now but
you get the point I'm really really
enjoying these vlogs I love making them
because it gives me a chance to connect
with you on it on a deeper level and
really show you what goes on behind the
scenes like this whole build is what my
next seeing sounds will be a church it's
great to have you come along in the
journey with me and as always if you
think it's [ __ ] or boring or there's
something more that you would like me to
introduce into these vlogs please let me
know in the comments I will always honor
my promise to put as much effort as
possible into every single video I make
and that's why for now I can sustain
doing five videos a month that'll be two
vlogs like this to seeing sounds and
then one of the BS videos which will be
at the end of every month but that's my
upload schedule and I'm glad we've had
this time to chat because I've been
exiled to the garage for a while now
kiss Gabe's has been inside all day
preparing a surprise for me and she's
ready to show me so I'm gonna take you
with for as much of the journey as she
allows
[Music]
what's it believe oh my god jabs what
the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] serious
there's a pipe running that hole okay
I'm coming into dreamland
when gaps and I started dating and we
spent our first night together she
bought us a blanket fort
so she engineered this piece of
architecture to remind me of that night
I've said this before but she's what a
special human I love you gaps
[Applause]
[Music]
and in this room that cabs cause the spa
which is my second favorite room
obviously after the red-light district
because it has a full-on heated pool
with bubbles sorry okay so I'm gonna
listen to gobs I'm gonna turn the camera
off and enjoy the wonders that this red
light district room has to offer and
I'll catch you in the morning for a
tattoo story but till then okay time for
a tattoo story I've been most excited to
share this tattoo story because every
single tattoo I've ever gotten this is
by far the most sentimental it's also
the most prison-like lookin tattoo but
the value that it carries is immense
okay so the story goes like this I was
living in a 5-star hotel at the time not
because I was making it rain quite the
opposite actually
I was 22 at the time and I just failed
at running my first digital media agency
called if not wine it broke my heart and
bank accounts but the fire burning
within you to create rad [ __ ] was more
alive than ever because of the people
that have been toward me through the
process like mr. Raymond Ackerman so a
good friend of mine that believed in my
vision made me crash in his spare room
at his hotel which is in the center
so that I could start up in the
freelance world from a solid foundation
you would always have all kinds of
creatives from all walks of life around
may need musicians but all so
like-minded work started fitting after
me really quickly and my dream of
becoming a film director was very much
in reach and this came from
understanding and practicing one very
important life changing quote often
opportunity is missed as it's disguised
in overalls and looks like work by
Thomas Edison just imagine being able to
alter your perception and understanding
that the harder you grind the more
opportunities present themselves so one
evening the school arrived at the hotel
who was covered in tattoos and randomly
offered to tattoo me and I said I know
exactly what to get so I got the
lightbulb with the writing just imagine
next to it to help me remember this
incredible quote by Thomas Edison it's
just it's an incredible feeling to get a
tattoo when I was so much younger
that still guides me it's part of my
navigation you know I look down into my
forearm and it keeps my thinking clear
and in earlier when I was talking about
how story blocks really helps me advance
my stories that helps me to take the
fragments from my imagination and turn
them into a motion scrapbook to give
them over to you and that's through the
incredible stock sight you know when
you've got something in your head and
you're like I wish I just got that shot
story blocks has your back you can just
go into story blocks and they've never
failed me to deliver the kind of shot
that I'm trying to portray which is
probably because story blocks unlimited
library has over 1 million assets and
they're always adding new content so do
yourself a favor if you haven't already
head over to story blocks com I'll link
it in the description below and sign up
today it's a super super powerful tool
for any creator ok this is the perfect
time to sign of this vlog well gabs gets
our favorite game fired up don't judge
me for this one Crash Bandicoot
because I've lied on social media for to
pretend that I like the computer
shooting games arrays yeah I just wanted
to say a huge thank you for all the
support on the vlogs and the subscribers
are growing and things are feeling
really good and I'm just in a really
good space and thank you for that I've
been reading the comments and trying to
engage as much as possible so y'all
please keep them coming and if you
haven't please subscribe it's just a
simple click of a button as well as to
turn on your notifications well so that
you don't miss the next video like the
crazy electric tools instrument box that
I've made and yeah I hope that you had
as much fun watching this video as gabs
and I and Joey had making it it's always
a blast and as always don't forget your
awesome brew and I'll see you next week
[Music]
you